يعد الذهب احد اهم الثروات القوميه في
السودان وتصنف السودان في المرتبه الثالثه
عشر عالميا بانتاج المعدن الاصفر السودان
تحتل ايضا المركز الثالث في افريقيا كاحد
اهم دول القاره انتاجا للمعدن النفيس كذلك
يصل احتياط السودان من الذهب الى نحو 1550
طنا فيما تشكل صادرات 45% من الصادرات
الاجماليه وينتج السودان حاليا نحو من 95
الى 100 طن سنويا ويعد الذهب السوداني احد
اكثر انواع الذهب تركيزا في العالم وتنتشر
منجم الذهب في مناطق متفرقه من السودان في
سحاره وجبال شرق نهر النيل وفي محاذاه
البحر الاحمر واعلى سلسله جبال البحر
الاحمر في شرق السودان وايضا في مناطق
شبال النوبه ومنطقه كوردوف كردفان شديده
الفقر وتنتشر فيها الحروب والمجرات
والصراعات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات